In this video, we're going to discuss authorship.
The main advice on authorship is to think
about the authorship before you write the
paper.
Especially, if you're the person drafting
the paper.
Think about who is going to get authorship.
Think about what the order will be.
Go through that with the team so that everybody
is on the same page and nobody feels slighted
later on.
There are two questions that you have to answer
with authorship.
First of all, who gets authorship?
Who are you going to include as an author
on your paper?
According to the International Committee of
Medical Journal Editors recommendation, authorship
should be based on the following 4 criteria:
1.
Substantial contributions to the conception
or design of the work; or the acquisition,
analysis, or interpretation of data for the
work; AND
1.
Drafting the work or revising it critically
for important intellectual content; AND
2.
Final approval of the version to be published;
AND
2.
Agreement to be accountable for all aspects
of the work in ensuring that questions related
to the accuracy or integrity of any part of
the work are appropriately investigated and
resolved.
The main criterion here is that if you are
an author listed on the paper, then you are
taking public responsibility for its content.
That's a high bar.
It means that if later, the paper is found
to have a problem.
If it’s found to have fraud, if it’s retracted.
You are responsible.
You are liable for those transgressions.
And that is going to reflect badly on you.
So, if you are not the primary author of the
paper, before you accept co-authorship, ask
yourself the question as to whether you want
to take that level of responsibility.
Do you really understand the ins and outs
of the paper well enough?
You have to decide whether you have been sufficiently
involved with its content to feel that you
can take public responsibility.
If you're the one writing the paper and trying
to decide on authors, keep in mind that most
people don't want to be included on your paper
unless they have been fully involved.
You can always put them in the acknowledgment
section if you think that they have assisted
in part of the study but not sufficiently
involved to qualify them to be co-author.
There is also the issue of order, what order
with the authors appear in?
In general, order implies the authors' relative
contributions.
The first author is usually the person who
wrote up the draft of the paper, might have
been the person who collected all the data,
often a graduate student, or a junior person.
And the last position is usually the senior
author, the head of the lab or research team,
or the senior person who oversaw the research.
That's a position of stature as well.
Sometimes you'll have dual first authors,
if maybe two graduate students worked on it
together equally.
In between the first and last positions, you
should put everyone else in their order of
their contributions.
If it's not clear if the rest of the authors
contributed equally without much differentiation,
you could consider putting them in alphabetical
order or even reverse alphabetical order.
And sometimes you get these large working
groups with lots and lots of people in international
collaborations.
Those large working groups can be cited as
a group because they often comprise hundreds
of authors.
Papers also have an acknowledgements section.
That's where you are going to cite any funding
sources.
If you're a graduate student who is on a certain
fellowship, make sure you cite your funding
source there.
If it was a grant funded study, you're going
to mention the grant there.
This is also a good place to acknowledge people
who you don't feel merit authorship, and who
probably don't want to be authors on the paper,
but maybe they gave you some materials, or
they offered some statistical consulting or
some other advice.
It's a way to acknowledge those people without
making them take on the role of author.
There is also an ethical issues of ghost authorship
and guest authorship.
This is a hot topic particularly in the medical
literature.
It's been written about in the New York Times
and its had some pretty profound influence
on the medical literature.
It's important that you are aware of these
practices.
Obviously, they are to be avoided when it
comes to authorship.
A ghost author is a professional writer who
usually a company hires to draft a manuscript.
At the end of the day the writer is not listed
as an author on the manuscript though they
may have written the whole paper.
Hence the term, ghost authorship.
There's nothing wrong with professional writers
being involved in the writing process.
Scientists can certainly use the help of writers,
but it's the lack of transparency that's the
problem here.
The related type of authorship is guest authorship,
or sometimes called honorary authorship.
This is when a company does a study, analyzes
the data, draws their conclusions, drafts
the paper, then they call or email an academic
researcher at a prestigious university and
invite them to be an author.
That academic researcher certainly can't take
public responsibility for the study.
But they're often willing to lend their name
because drug company studies are often large
high quality clinical trials that get published
in great journals, and this goes on the academics
resume.
The drug company meanwhile gets to bolster
their papers credibility by leading researchers
to believe that an outside independent unbiased
expert was a driving force in the study.
Obviously, this is misleading if in fact the
academic was only minimally involved and is
simply lending their name, and their institution's
name to the paper.
It's unclear how common these types of unethical
authorship practices are in the literature.
But a study in the British Medical Journal
in 2011 that surveyed top medical journals
found evidence of honorary or guest authorship
in 17.6% of papers.
And evidence of ghost authorship in 7.6% of
papers.
So at least in 2011, this practice was fairly
pervasive.
If you're interested in learning more about
this, the medical community learned a lot
about this practice because of litigation
surrounding the drug Vioxx.
Merck was being sued over the drug Vioxx,
which was to found to increase the risk of
heart attacks.
Because of the court trials, internal company
documents entered the public domain.
And there's a fascinating article in JAMA
from 2008, where some researchers systematically
reviewed 250 court documents related to published
clinical trial and published review papers.
What they found was shocking.
The researchers reviewed emails and other
documents related to 24 clinical trial papers
that Merck was involved with.
Here's what they found:
• Documents were found describing Merck
employees working either independently or
in collaboration with medical publishing companies
to prepare manuscripts and subsequently recruiting
external academically affiliated investigators
to be authors.
• Recruited authors were frequently placed
in the first and second positions of the authorship
list.
• The use of guest or honorary authorship
was an accepted practice at Merck apparently.
They also looked at 72 review papers that
the company was involved in publishing.
They found:
• Merck marketing employees developing plans
for manuscripts, contracting with medical
publishing companies to ghostwrite manuscripts,
and recruiting external, academically affiliated
investigators to be authors.
• Recruited authors were commonly the sole
author on the manuscript and offered honoraria
for their participation.
• Only half of the review articles even
disclosed that Merck had sponsored those papers.
That's quite insidious and you can see that
this could have profound impact on the medical
literature.
Merck could actually put this whole set of
opinions and perspectives out in the medical
literature with it having the stamp of coming
from an academic institution, when it really
came from the drug company marketing people.
You can see why this has been such a hot issue.
Just to give you an idea, this is an actual
internal company email that was made public
during the court trial.
It shows you how blatant this practice is.
The company writes to the potential guest
author:
“I would like to invite you to be an author
on the abstract and manuscript for this study.
We are currently preparing both for submission
before the end of this year.
Could you please let me know if you would
be interested in authorship on both the abstract
and manuscript, one of the two planned publications,
or none?
In making your decision, you may want to take
into consideration that the results of this
study were negative at first glance.”
Basically, the company is giving out authorship
like a gift.
And they're allowing the researcher to choose
whether or not they want to accept this gift
based on how the study results happened to
come out.
Clearly the author being invited here has
no basis for taking public responsibility
for the content of these articles.
Obviously, this researcher was not heavily
involved in the analysis, because the analysis
is already done, or the writing of the paper,
it's already being drafted.
This is a clear case of guest authorship.
And the trial turned up many emails like this
that made it obvious as to what was going
on.
In summary, naming authors on a scientific
paper ensures that the appropriate individuals
get credit, and are accountable, for the research.
Deliberately misrepresenting a scientist's
relationship to their work is considered to
be a form of misconduct that undermines confidence
in the reporting of the work itself.